so as we continue our series on the
Marvel Universe vs. the Punisher we pick
up now with a conclusion of the event
and the reveal of the kingpin has taken
over New York City proper along with his
tribe of cannibalistic heroes and
villains so with the last issue seen the
Punisher being hit from behind by Wilson
Fisk after coming to the realization
that Fisk had been manipulated the
actions of the cannibals from the time
the outbreak first started up into the
current day in order to solidify his
control over New York a problem faced by
Cassel is that in his mind his current
predicament isn't really the fault of
spider-man so much as it was his
willingness to go out on a limb and
offer assistance to Peter
however these feelings are mingled with
the lessons he learned in the last issue
regarding the importance of fighting for
something greater than himself and that
even if he doesn't see himself as the
leader of the uninfected humans the fact
that he's been killing cannibals and
ensuring the safety of the uninfected
humans in the process has solidified the
fact that he is their leader and so
after through only several flashbangs
into the area allowing him to attempt to
escape with Mary Jane while leaving
kingpin and his tribe blind in the
process he's attacked by Sauron meta
sidetrack here Sauron is a character
that we haven't really talked about
before but mostly this was due to the
fact that we haven't really had a reason
to
but Sauron is actually a man named Karl
Lykos who was bitten by radioactive
pterodactyls which mutated his genome
allowing him to drain others of their
energy the issue with this is that while
draining normal humans allows Karl Lykos
some measure of enhanced abilities his
mutation resulted in a Bruce Banner
Incredible Hulk dichotomy meaning that
when Karl Lykos absorbs the energy of
superhumans he takes on the form of
Sauron a humanoid pterodactyl which acts
in accordance with his own wishes and
without like us knowing what Sauron is
doing having said that were Punisher
attempts to hold his own after a short
battle castle is knocked unconscious
after being flung against the wall after
which he waked up as a prisoner of the
kingpin Networking pan and his group
tortured Punisher for information on
where spider-man is located during a
moment of reflection while refusing to
provide an answer Mayberry provides us
with an amazing flashback or Punisher
gives us as the reader his perspective
on how we used to view the world versus
how we views it now what castle tells us
is that despite operating to gain
revenge for the deaths of his family
instead of feeling some measure of
success with each
that he murdered instead he didn't
actually feel anything now this requires
us to read a bit between the lines on
what Maybury is saying but the overall
theme here is that the deaths of castles
family created his own personal hell in
the form of his family's desk creating a
psychotic break which removed Punisher
from feeling anything whenever he
committed his murders now where he does
go on to say that eliminating the
world's criminals was based on the
premise of wiping the world clean of
evil and allowing only the pure to exist
Castle had not taken into account the
concept of human nature and that as long
as humans were procreating and producing
offspring there would always be
individuals who grew to become criminals
for a multitude of reasons some of which
were predictable and some of which were
not however when the world went to pot
and was over and by cannibals instead of
having to differentiate between
criminals and good guys or having to
deal with heroes whose moral compass
placed roadblocks in his path instead
with all of the humans and hiding
Punisher was able to take the stance of
himself versus the Marvel Universe where
he could literally travel a landscape of
New York and Carroll virtually anyone
and everyone that he saw since cannibals
we're the only individuals brave enough
to travel in plain sight now after this
bit of reflection from the Punisher is
revealed that while he had been held
prisoner by kingpin and his forces the
priests and the young boy had attempted
a rescue mission by gathering various
arms and armor from castles base of
operations and infiltrating the camp now
while they were called by jaime mad
rocks as the multiple man and held
prisoner I'd like you to keep this in
the forefront since this will be an
instrument for the conclusion of the
story but transitioning back to the
Punisher with kingpin threatening to
kill Mary Jane and her unborn child as
well as consume them both after
overpowering one of kingpins henchmen
Mary Jane puts herself in a no-win
situation what I mean here is that
because the cannibals consumed humans if
Mary Jane kills herself
the kingpin and his crew would simply
eat her her unborn child and the
Punisher as well as track down
spider-man anyway but if she lives
she'll remain in the same situation that
she's currently in now transitioning
away from the situation for a minute and
focusing on Deadpool where his healing
factor had kept him from dying when
Punisher threw grenades at everyone he
was taken prisoner in the Pens under the
watch of the Red Skull now maybe a
throws a bit of humor into this part of
the story in likeness of the mainstream
Deadpool the only real inclusion of this
bit was to provide an out for the
conclusion of the store
what I mean here is that after taking
out red skull and escaping the prison
after summing across the weapons brought
by the priests and the young boy
wait orchestrates everyone's escaped by
taking out one of the henchmen and
dropping the weapons where they could be
reached by Mary Jane using the momentary
distraction to free Frank Castle and
allow him to do the Lord's work after
throwing grenades into the crowd he
unloads with an absolute hail of bullets
killing all of kingpins henchmen raging
from Domino to Sauron to multiple man
and everyone in between
following this where King Creon
initially argues a castle wants to see
him beg or else plead for his life
instead of giving kingpin the
opportunity to finish castle simply
shoots him in the face and walks away
and so transition into the reunion of
Peter Parker and Mary Jane Watson where
the last three issues had focused on
castle coming to grips with his role in
the post-apocalyptic landscape and the
fact that the situation represented
itself in a way where a peace could be
achieved between the forces of Parker
and Castle instead of upholding his into
the bargain and maintaining a peaceful
coexistence between the cannibals in the
humans instead Punisher kills spider-man
arguing that he doesn't make deals with
monsters now something that I actually
want to do here is I want to focus on
this for a second while maybe Reed
doesn't tell us why castle did this if I
can offer my own opinion on the subject
I would argue that the reason for this
was that Punisher himself doesn't
believe he deserves to be happy the
reason why I make this case is that the
Punishers life is defined by his desire
for revenge and killing virtually all
criminals he came across however the
prospect of walking away from this
lifestyle would fly in the face of his
very existence meaning that without an
enemy or a war to fight his life would
be virtually pointless and that he
wouldn't have a reason to exist now
while I wouldn't swear to this line of
logic is gospel truth because he
considers himself to be the same monster
as those that he's been fighting but
operating under a different cause as the
story comes to a close and the remaining
humans leave New York
Punisher continues his task of killing
whatever cannibals remain in New York
after which were left to guess where
he'll go
with that being said we're gonna bring
this video to an end I hope you guys
enjoyed it and let me know what you guys
think about this story punisher vs. the
marvel universe I personally really
really enjoyed I thought it was one of
the best Punisher stories that I've read
in a long time over that being said that
we'll catch you guys later
face